follow your heart I got a great question
I love this question for my youtube
viewers love you guys Jean who wrote in
and asked me this several years ago I
retired from my job engineering but I
continued with my nonprofit activity as
a chairperson this year I decided I
wanted to start a new career real estate
and I need some advice should I continue
with my nonprofit activity as
chairperson or should I let it go and
focus on real estate I'm really 50/50 on
on it and I could see many benefits on
both decisions if I continue my
nonprofit activity I could gain exposure
to future buyers and salaries in real
estate and continue relationship with
golfers I play with but sometimes I feel
distracted and feel like there are too
many irons in the fire if I could
discontinue my nonprofit activity I
would gain much more learning time for a
new career and be able to focus on
something new but I feel like you lose
exposure relationship some contacts Jean
this is such a fantastic question and
what you need to do is get out of your
head you got to get out of your head
stop making your lists of pros and cons
because whenever you have a super
important life decision you got to make
like this you have to think about it not
with your head but act from your heart
you got to do what's right for you what
you feel is the best thing and don't
worry about your business because that
will take care of itself here's what I
mean you became a chairperson of this
golf organization and great if that's
something you're loved you passionate
about if you're pouring your heart into
it it's gonna be successful if you are
hanging on just to promote your real
estate business then you're doing a
disservice to everybody you're not gonna
be a great chairperson anymore if your
heart's not in it you're going to be
constantly distracted from your business
- you're gonna feel like it's a big
weight around your ankles what you need
to do is something that you're
passionate about if you still love being
the chairperson then pour your heart
into it don't worry about the real
estate business side of it that's not
why you're doing it you're doing it
because it's the right thing to do
you're doing it because it makes you
come alive and as a result you're gonna
get a lot of business from it you're
gonna make great contacts
you're gonna make you're gonna meet
potential buyers and sellers and it's
going to help your real estate
but that's not why you're doing it
you're doing it because you love it and
if you're doing it just to try to help
your business the organization is not
going to do well and your business is
not going to do well and it's a
disservice to you because you should be
doing something that you're passionate
about and to the service to the charity
that you're a part of because they have
somebody at the head who's not
passionate what they're doing anymore
and it's just trying to milk it for
business reasons and when that happens
nobody wins so what I encourage you to
do is look into your heart and figure
out which one feels right
would you really miss this charity golf
stuff if you weren't doing it anymore do
you feel like you still have a lot to
contribute to it do you still want to
pull yourself into it or not and if the
answer is no then let it go that's okay
you're pouring your heart into something
new real estate this is such an
important move for anybody making a
major life decision because for some
reason we're taught you know make a list
pros and cons and see which one adds up
more and that's - when you go with and
that's that's probably the worst advice
you can give somebody when they're
making a huge decision because when
you're making decisions based on
information that currently exists you're
probably going to make the wrong one and
it could look great on paper right it
can make it could look amazing on papers
the best opportunity ever but if you
can't pour your heart into it
you're never gonna achieve success and
you can look at an opportunity that
looks terrible on paper does nobody want
to get into but if you pour your passion
into it you could turn that into a
success so you have to follow your heart
that's the key and by the way you're
getting the real estate you should apply
the same thing for that - and I hope you
did and I believe that you did but a lot
of people when they're making a career
jump trying out a new opportunity if
you're getting the real estate because
you love working with people because you
love the idea of helping people find a
new home because you love making
people's lives convenient because you're
gonna take pride and be able to say you
should move into this house that's built
well you should raise a family there but
that's why you're doing it then jump all
in but if you're becoming a real estate
agent because you think it's a quick
made a way to make some extra money
you're never gonna be successful and
again could look great like maybe now
it's booing and everybody wants to be a
real estate agent brain it looks great
this is the you know the magazines that
show the hot opportunity to get into it
yeah I'm gonna I'm gonna dive into that
that's where I belong you know that's
awesome here's a way to make some cash
if you don't love it you're never going
to be successful no matter how good it
looks on paper so throw away your list
throw away your pros and cons and the
5050 odds on both take some time think
about what's best for you what you're
going to love where you're gonna throw
your passion into and make your decision
off of that and I promise you it'll be
the best thing for you it'll be the best
thing for the charity organization and
it'll be the best thing for your company
belief those be watching you like the
video you can subscribe to the channel
to see more videos like it you can
support me by clicking on the link in
the description and leave a comment let
me know you think I love your comments
coming in they mean so much to me so
thank you and I'll see you soon